well first of all uh thanks for having
me here today i'm fabricio frasca and
i'm a research scientist at twitter but
i'm also a
phd student actually at imperial college
london
uh today we're gonna talk about
subgraphs for more expressive graphical
networks
uh let me
explain a little bit uh more about it
so
uh i would like to talk about what i
call the subgraph gnn wave
uh
that is advances in more powerful
graphical networks in the last year
basically it's what i where we observed
basically observed a surge in a series
of approaches sharing common themes that
is the use of subgraphs all concurrent
uh to each other and uh we somehow
gathered them and
uh to collect to discuss them together
as a graph gnns and so we're gonna
briefly talk about some of these
approaches at the beginning and then in
the second part of the talk i'm gonna uh
focus on a more specific uh approach
that is equivalent to graphic
degradation networks this is a framework
that um seems like to unify um
at the other s that has been proposed in
the in the past year and it's a
concurrent work i covered
last year with
other amazing collaborators uh so the
second part of the talk will go more in
detail about this framework
okay so let's start with some background
and motivation
uh i guess at this point of the
geometric deep learning course probably
you're very familiar with this so
probably yeah i guess we can we can go a
little bit quick on this but uh in
essence essentially we know what a gnn
is right so gnn is uh or a graphical
network is our parameterized function of
graphs uh whose parameters we would like
to learn
uh from data right
and uh probably the most common family
of uh graphene networks uh is uh
those that is called message passing
your network family that is all those
gnns which update not representations
alternatively uh by exchanging messages
with the neighbors
uh we can keep repeating message passing
for a certain number of layers until in
the end we can perform a readout
operation to obtain a representation for
the overall
graph in the graph
and
a very strong
property and very actually advantageous
property of message passing your
networks is that as they were defined in
the original formulation their
permutation equivalent or invariant
difficulty to the final graph
representation
this is a very important inductive bias
in general
but that would like to retain right but
what's the matter with uh mpns or
message passing neural networks so the
matter as you may have probably seen
during this weeks is that no matter how
we
design the message and update functions
still they are bounded in expressive
power that is they are not universal
models so there are some functions
defined on graphs which cannot probably
learn with a message passing into an
address
and
this has been characterized in terms of
uh not being able to distinguish
non-isomorphic graphs some of it some
isomorphic grass and in particular uh
very uh
so um
a series of very interesting papers i've
shown that essentially the the upper
bound on the expressive power of npns is
that of the one up real test
which is um
normally fast heuristic that has been
designed uh in the gravity community in
in the past century to distinguish
neuromorphic graphs and the way it works
is basically data rates call refinement
steps very similarly to what we do in
message passing so initially if say that
we would like to distinguish two
possibly non-isomorphic graphs we assign
the same color to every node and then we
keep updating node colors by
injectively hashing together the current
node color for a certain node along with
this multiset of colors from neighbors
and we keep doing this and at each time
at every step at every round as this is
called we can gather the colors of nodes
into histograms
and can compare histograms to
between
between different graphs and as as soon
as the histograms diverge then we can
say that the two graphs are
non-isomorphic
so
the problem with this approach is that
there are some non-isomorphic graphs
which instead are not distinguished so
they will always be mapped to the same
histogram and so
for example this is an infamous pair of
molecules that
so they are two distinct molecules
they're real-world molecules they're
called the colon and bicycle penta
uh
they are they of course as you can see
they have a different molecular
structure and a different associated
graph
but indeed uh what happens is that they
cannot be distinguished by the wl test
so they will be assigned the same
histogram
and therefore they will be represented
in the same way
and uh the related limitations of this
test is that it cannot count non-trivial
patterns such as for example the number
of triangles or
cycles in a graph cannot really be
complete but this approach
and so for example in this case the
approach is not able to tell well in the
first molecule we have two um
we have two six rings for example
um
all these limitations which have real
practical uh implications they are
inherited directly by mpns because of uh
what it has been shown that basically uh
this combinatory algorithm upper bounds
the expressive power of npns so this is
to
somehow recap why it is important to
study the expressive power of our
approaches of gnns in particular
and in the past years uh there's been a
lot of effort in trying to design uh
graphical networks which go beyond the
expressive power of this commentary
algorithm
is there any question
no okay
uh there is no question
okay
i could use some noise but yeah feel
free to interrupt me at any time
um so uh
what's going on so going on basically
yeah i was saying in the past years
there's been a lot of effort in trying
to design novel architectures that are
probably more expressive than 1wl and
essentially the first approach is trying
to mimic
either the generalization of this
combinatorial algorithm which are called
kwl
tests
they are strictly more powerful than the
standard wl algorithm
but the problem is that
essentially the gnns that are inspired
by these
algorithms they are non-local so they
lose this locality inductive bias which
is also a very interesting and important
data bias in message passing neural
networks and at the same time they they
easily get computationally intractable
for uh cadence parameter k uh greater or
equal than three which is actually what
we need to get more expressive
gns
so this is not really a feasible
approach especially in practice
at the other end of the spectrum there
are approaches where instead try to
get inspiration from
algorithms for distributed computing
whereas the idea sorry whereby the idea
is that we can still use a standard
message passing a network but we can
provide it with a way to
identify uniquely nodes in the graph so
the idea is that this models can even
be made universal if we
allow them to uniquely identify centers
of these messages during the message
masking step and the way you would do
this is typically in order to get unique
identifiers you you use random node
features uh sampled at any inference
step
uh the problem with this approach is
that it because of this inherent
randomness it's not uh equivalent to
permutation
and um the permutations and this uh
empirically it has been shown that uh it
really uh hinders uh generalization so
it's it really creates problems in
trying to generalize to test uh graphs
and scene graphs
uh maybe in a middle ground uh could be
uh the following so there are these uh
works which try to basically um
consider substructures in the graphs
especially those substructures which are
not
basically uh to which the standard uh
master passenger networks are bind to
and they either do message passing
directly on top of them
or they consider the presence of the
substructures to modulate message
passing between nodes
let me start with maybe this particular
approach grass structure networks
which i believe is can be considered as
upper cursor to this wave of subgraph
gene ends we're going to talk about in a
second
so the idea is
instead of considering random node
features as not identifiers what i can
do is i can
choose a bank of substructures
for example triangles cycles
rings clicks
and then i can mesh them on top of the
input graph and for each node i can say
well this node belongs to for example
one triangle a one five cycle and maybe
uh two four clicks for example so all
these statistics can be uh gathered
together to form somehow what we can
consider as uh positional encodings
structural encodings or enough in us in
a way identifiers they are not unique
identifiers of course but they still
they're they are still able to break
local symmetries that would lead
basically standard wl test or message
passenger networks to failure
because basically each node is able to
modulate the the messages coming from
neighbors depending on some features uh
structural features that standard mpns
would not be able to capture and because
of this reason uh this approach is
actually strictly more powerful than 1wl
for a certain choice of
of substructures
and other pros are that basically in
this way we inject a very powerful um uh
bias into the network which can be uh
linked to the domain knowledge we have
at hand so for example if you're working
with molecules we are
doing molecular modelling we know that
rings are very important and so the fact
that we count rings and we know uh to
how many rings are not belong to uh this
becomes a very uh useful feature to have
uh it retains permutation equivalence
which is very good and it has low
message passing complexity it's the same
complexity as standard message passing
neural networks the problem with this is
that
uh
counting the substructures in the first
pla in the first place
is actually might be actually
computationally intractable in some
cases
and of course it's not really clear how
to design uh the bank the substructure
bank so which substrate
to actually match on top of the input
graphs
this may depend on domain knowledge but
sometimes we don't really have this
right so this is some somehow
problematic to some extent
but still nonetheless i think i believe
this is a kind of uh we consider the
kind of precursors to this wave of
approaches which emerged in the last
year concurrently
and we're going to talk about this uh
now
um
the the common theme is the use of
graphs and we will see in a second how
and
i've listed here some of them uh dropout
gnns reconstruction gnns gns kernel we
also have the framework i was talking
about uh
is equivalent uh subgraph aggregation
networks or essence
there are many others you can find them
uh in michael's uh towards the science
blog post uh we ordered along with some
of the orders of these papers and yeah
here i put the link i can share the
slides afterwards so you can take a look
so let's uh start to uh take a look at
these approaches let's start from
dropout gnn
okay so what's the the key concept so
the the concept is that
so sub graphs well substructures we know
are important but they might be
it might be computationally expensive to
match them and it's not really clear how
to as i was saying how to sometimes how
to choose them right but still what we
can do is
we can actually find importance of
graphs very cheaply by subtraction so
what i mean is we may have two graphs
which are
not distinguishable by the standard wl
algorithm or let's say message passing
near networks
but they may contain some graphs which
are easily separated by these algorithms
and the way we can expose the subgraphs
is simply by dropping some nodes
uh very cheaply so in a kind of almost
blind fashion right
so what they propose in this paper is
you can drop
each node independently with a certain
probability
you run a message passing your network
on the resulting graph which is is
basically it's in itself a subgraph of
the original graph we repeat this
approach for a certain number of times
and then we aggregate the embeddings
that we got
and uh this seems to be very a very
native approach but indeed
what happens is that every node sees a
slightly different neighborhood each
time and this resolves the ambiguities
this this local sea images that leads uh
basically double l to failure and the
the orders show that this uh is enough
to um
with some bounds to uh get an expressive
power which is greater than other
messenger passing neural networks i'm
gonna just present you know this the
main ideas and then but we can try to um
formalize this all um intuitions um
better later when we talk about uh the
uh econ framework so let me uh directly
go to reconstruction neural nets just to
you know give uh uh the big picture so
it's a very similar approach
the idea is that uh we can build on top
of uh a famous uh
popular conjecture in the graph theory
community that states that it may
actually that it is possible to recover
a graph
so reconstruct a graph from the
collection of node deleteds are graphs
of all nodes and graphs so the idea is
you take a graph
uh you delete one node at a time and all
the connectivity involving that node
each of these subgraphs you get they are
called cards you can gather all the
cards in in a bag or you know
what they call a deck
and uh if you consider the deck and you
can
reconstruct the original graph just
looking at the cards in the deck
so
the others
would basically propose something like
this
yes yeah there is a question
sure
yes
let me take a look
was light 11 how do you choose r is it a
number parameter uh yes yes of course um
[Music]
it has also an impact um
on the performance and
uh the the other but not just on the
performance also on the uh
properties of the algorithm itself you
can see it's uh if r is not um
so if r is actually the um
large enough you you might be uh
guaranteed to sample basically all
possible not the leaders are grasses you
delete for example one at a time so
uh being it um
let's say a stochastic process uh the
orders actually show that you can obtain
a bounds on for example the expressive
power of this approach based on the
cyber parameter but in practice yes you
will choose them in fact the others
suggests that um
you don't really need a very large r in
practice because many times most of the
time basically the times you
it's sufficient to drop a few nodes to
really expose importance of graphs
but yes in principle it's not a
parameter
is this answered equation or
okay let me continue but yeah feel free
to keep interrupting me if there's
anything else
uh you want to talk about um
okay uh
so let's get back to the
to the reconstruction neural networks so
the idea is i can take a graph
generate all the collection of node read
sub graphs encode each of these
subgraphs independently and then
aggregate the encodings in a permutation
environment fashion if i do this uh
given that i have all possible sub
graphs and i
uh aggregate the encodings in a
preparation for infection then i have an
overall architecture which is actually a
permutation variant
uh and if the reconstruction conjecture
holds this approach is actually um
universal right
so you may you might think well but is
this really the case that we built on
top of a conjecture well the conjecture
has been improved for uh all graphs with
um
the number of a number of nodes up to i
think 10 or 11 uh and it has been proved
to actually hold for uh uh families of
special families of crafts
and what i mean is there is some shirt
feeling that it might hold
uh but other than this uh the the orders
in the paper show that actually you can
really extract interesting features by
this process of not removal
uh there's actually a caveat in this
that is
you
well you know point two in the recipe
says encode each of these subgraphs
independently right but
what you would need to do is to encode
these subgraphs in a unique way right
but
encoding as a graph is as hard as
encoding a graph right because it's a
graph is a graph itself
so
the only way to but but the problem is
actually that we don't really have a
universal encoder for graphs this is the
problem you're trying to solve today
um so
what you can do is you can keep doing
this recursively until you
get basically some graphs which are very
small and you can enumerate the atomic
types in the case yes you may be
universal but the problem with this if
the reconstruction conjecture holds of
course but the problem with this
approach is that uh the computational
complexity will get exponential right so
what the others propose is well you know
what i can actually use an mpn as a card
encoder so to encode the sub graphs
so the result the model only
approximates the conjecture regime
because as we are as we said already
mpns are not universal right but yet
even if this seems a nahiv approach yet
this can be probably expressive and the
expressive power of this approach
depends on k that is on the number of
nodes we retain after the
version
so for example the others prove that if
k is uh n minus one so if we delete one
node at a time we can actually
distinguish graphs as the circle skip
link graphs i have a pair here in the
slide which cannot be distinguished by
standalone pngs and so this make along
with other properties this makes this
approach strictly more powerful than not
npn's
and for
k equal to n minus two so if we delete
two nodes at a time we can even
distinguish graphs which are not
distinguished by three double l which is
even an even stronger generalization of
wl
um
so you start to see like that uh
ends they can somehow be used as
subroutines uh to approximate
some subgraph or some more feasible
we'll get to this in a second
i want to first show you another
approach which is slightly different
than this
it's called gns kernel
okay so the others uh the motivation is
according to the others is well you know
the bottleneck of standard double color
refinement is that uh this approach
works by hashing in in a sense hashing
stars right
so because i we take the color of a
certain node and the colors of the
neighboring nodes but in so doing we
completely ignore the connective the
local connectivity you know between for
example between the neighbors
um
and according to the others this is the
fundamental bottleneck that leads wl to
its uh
to its failures right
so what they propose is to to shift from
encoding stars
to uh encoding actually ego nets or ego
subgraphs that is basically the complete
graph obtained induced by uh by the
neighbors over certain nodes up to a
certain depth for example
we can consider whether the first hop or
like one op neighborhood or to help
neighbors and so on again here we have a
parameter k
uh which is actually considered to be
another parameter that is the depth of
this graphs right
but okay what do we do with these
subgraphs with this econets
so the idea is that we can
propose a variant of the standard w
algorithm whereby
we change the update rule right so
instead of hashing as i was saying
uh the the color of the of
the current color of a node and the
colors of the of the neighbors we hash
directly the all subgraph
around a certain node
um okay the problem with this similarly
as what we observed before with with
cards and x right so the problem is that
an injective hash of a sub graph is
indeed as hard as injectively hashing a
graph that is as encoding a graph
universally
so
again
we can
approximate this encoding by running an
internal inner nested w procedure only
on the local graph
so to recap basically
this subgraph 1wl start variant is an
approximation of this more powerful
subgraph 1wl approach
whereby
instead of computing an injective ash or
vanigonet which is very hard
we run an internal nested wl approach
only to encode the subgraph and we use
the the output from this w internal wl
approach to actually update the color of
a node in this case
is the red node in the picture
and
again what we can do is we can
design a neural counterpart of this
subgraph one wl star algorithm whereas
whereby instead of running wl we
actually run an internal nested gnn
so how does this work so instead of
doing standard message passing we update
the representation of a node by running
a nest
a nested gnn on its uh egonet we
repeat so what i mean is internally we
perform message passing between the
nodes in the sigonet we compute a
readout we get a representation of the c
net and we use this representation of
the ignite exactly to update the
representation of the of the root node
of the root of the unit and we can keep
doing this for some for many layers
and you can see already that there is an
interesting um
there's something interesting uh
popping up now that is
we can parameterize this gnn differently
right
so for example one thing we can do is we
can parameterize it with a message
passing your network so as i was saying
we do message passing internally in a
nested fashion
um and this can be made as powerful as
subgraph on the blstar which the others
show
it's strictly more powerful than one
well so we get actually more expressive
power than standard message passing into
our networks by simply running this
nested uh message passing on top of igor
nets
and
but what we can do is we can actually
use even more powerful although more
expensive of course encoders such as uh
ppgn from our own ad headquarters which
is has been shown to be
as powerful as 3wl and if you do this if
you use vpgn as an encoder for these
eagerness you can actually
distinguish
graphs which are not distinguished by
3wl so again we have the same uh in
famous example here these two strongly
regular graphs if you consider the red
uh the egonet around these red nodes
this egoness can be distinguished by uh
ppgn so it means that these two graphs
can be distinguished by ppg and as
kernel as they call it this overall
bi-level if you wish approach
um let's wrap up a little bit so what
what we have so we have that there are
some common themes emerging um
we have uh these approaches with little
to no pre-engineering
in a sense that we don't really need to
uh basically select the sub graphs to
match on top of a certain
graph
we can let importance of graphs directly
emerge by perturbing the original graph
but in a way that doesn't really require
any particular and
engineer
[Music]
okay
what else
we still stay within the remits of
message passing in the sense that uh we
don't really abandon message passing
completely in the past it's been
conjectured that in order to really
break bottleneck of expressive power one
should somehow abandon message passing
completely for different approaches but
what we are seeing here is that we are
not abandoning this passing we use
message passing and
um
this uh as
advantages as we know so message passing
is local it is scalable in terms of
computation and it's very easy to
implement
but how is this used it's used as a sort
of subroutine as we saw right so it's
often used to somehow approximate sub
graph uh encoding
uh subgraph uh as more phases if you
wish
and
this approach which uh to some extent
might seem a little bit uh it's already
enough to gain expressive power
nonetheless
um let's
jump now into another approach uh
covariance of graph aggregation networks
more into detail
um
okay
so this is a work i co-holder with
specific babylock water clean
uh
bala uh
streaming
sorry srinivasan uh chiang kai gopinath
a lot of students uh michael bronstein
and aguei maron
so the it's a concurrent work we
published last year and more than a
model it's an overall framework we can
consider it as an overall framework
and i'll explain you why in a second
it provides additional characterization
through the lens of equivalence and i
think because of this reason it might be
interesting to take a look at this
during this
course and it unifies and generalizes
many other methods for example the
methods we have seen so far
i was saying that there were many
students in this project because this
project actually sparked from a summer
school
that's london geometry machine learning
summer school in
2021 basically last year which i invite
you to take a look at and possibly apply
for next year it's uh it's a great um
it's a great um summer school
okay
so
let's recap so what do we want we want
some
models or gnn which is probably
expressive at least more expressive than
standard 1wl or standard mpns
we would like to reduce engineering as
much as possible to keep the
computational complexity somewhat
tractable so we don't want to get to
you know
the very high
intractable computational complexity by
order gns
but at the same time we want to
retain equivalence because this is a
very strong inductive bias when we work
with graphs right
and
we recap that
the main intuition that is the intuition
shared by many others um many other um
subgraph gnns is that even if two graphs
are not distinguishable to impedance
they may contain some graphs which are
instead easily separated so what i mean
is for example if we take this uh
paragraphs here
these two graphs are not distinguished
by an empty n but if we simply remove
one edge then we can run an npn n on the
obtained subgraphs and they somehow all
of a sudden they become easily separate
they can be easily separated by an mpn
right so we would like to kind of
formalize this situation somewhere
so the way we can do it is
we can somehow design a recipe that is
we take a graph
we map this graph into a set of sub
subgraphs there is a bag of the graphs
with a certain function which we call a
selection policy which decides how to
extract some graphs for from an original
graph and then we would like to process
this bug in a principle way that is in a
way to respect the inherent symmetries
of this object
um
some possible policies are for example
not deletion
as deletion so we remove edges one at a
time instead of nodes or we can extract
igunes as in gns kernel right
but let's get to the
probably more interesting part like what
does it mean to
keep this equivalent so what are the
symmetries of this object okay so
if you consider a bag of graphs
we have actually two symmetries which
are related to one another by a direct
product and uh let me explain why so
each of graph in the back of course is a
graph itself right so we would like to
be
equivalent to not permutation so if we
promote the order of the nodes in some
graphs we we want to we want the the uh
the output of the network to um
basically um
have a um an equivalent response right
um
so so far so good i mean we we are used
to this but now we have a new access
right so we have also that we have
different subgraphs in a bag the bag is
fundamentally a set
so the order of the sub subgraphs in the
back is not really important right so we
would like the variance also to
permutations of the sub graphs in the
back
so as you can see we have two
permutation groups now
it's not just simply this the c one
single permutation groups
that is like permutation with respect to
the order of nodes now we also have
permutations with respect to the order
of subgraphs
and the super mutations actually are
related to each other in a direct
product and this is because there's um
something which which we can really um
leverage on that is
all the sub graphs come from the same
graph right
so
it is possible to align nodes between
the subgraphs in a way that a certain
node i in each subgraph can be traced
back to node i in the original graph
so
this means that when we permute the
nodes of uh of a graph we are allowed
actually to
permute the nodes of all the others of
graphs in the same manner so this means
that the internal permutation so the
permutation on the nodes of each
subgraph is the same across the bank
and this is a very important
intuition and i'll explain why uh in uh
in these next slides
but
first of all we have this direct product
between these two permutations groups
right so how do we design a layer which
is a good variant to this
so fortunately uh we there is a work
that has been
published in in 2020 which study exactly
the case where you would like to design
a layer equivalent to a direct product
between
sorry between two symmetry groups where
the outer symmetry is actually a
permutation
so as exactly as in our case the
internal symmetry
um so maybe let's recap so in our case
we have two symmetries right so an
external one which is
we permute uh the sub graphs in the back
and we have an internal one that is we
permute nodes in the sub graphs right
so this work actually uh dealt with the
case where we have an external
permutation symmetry as in our case
and an internal image which can be any
action
in our case this is another permutation
but it's uh it's our specific use case
so other
use cases for example for this general
approach could be you have a set of
images and you would like to um
to
process the set of images in an
equivalent way so in that case the
internal symmetry would be translation
right
but anyway let's get to the juice how
how can we uh design this layer in a way
to be maximally expressive and
equivalent to this uh symmetry group so
you need two blocks you need l1 and l2
you need a first block which l1 which is
a siamese component
equivalent to the internal symmetry so
in the case of images this will be for
example a convolution lay convolutional
layer and this is applied with the same
ways to all
elements in the set so for example to
all images in parallel
and then you have a second block l2
which is still equivalent to the
internal symmetry so it's still uh for
example in the case of images it's still
a convolutional layer but it does no
don't shared weight so it's a different
set of weights with respect to the first
block and this block is applied to the
submission the aggregation of the input
element so in this case the summation of
the input images
and you take the outputs from
this two blocks and then you
sum them together and this will
correspond to the output of the layer
so again we have a siamese component
this is this here in blue
and an information sharing component if
you wish with a different set of
parameters which acts on the submission
the aggregation of the inputs
and we can do the same so
in our case we don't have we won't have
a convolutional layers of course
but what we're going to have is we need
a block
a layer which is equivalent not to
translation but
two permutations because we are dealing
with subgraphs and the internal symmetry
is a permutation symmetry right
so we have something very similar with
the uh with the difference being that
this internal blocks uh which here we
have orange and yellow and one and two
or if you wish mu one two
uh they are message passing neural
networks or in general gnns which we
know to be equivalent to permutations
so we have basically that
we instantiate two dnns
one
is shared and is applied in a siamese
fashion to each subgraph to each of the
graphs in the back
and we have another mpn or gnn which is
applied to the summation of the
subgraphs where summation means that we
aggregate the node features for each of
the sub graphs
along with the um with the connectivity
so this um so in a way that basically we
uh get the output from these two blocks
from these two distinct npns and we sum
sum them and this will be the new
representation for each node in each
subgraph
okay
now we can also do something that is we
can completely disable the second part
mu2 that is this uh information sharing
component what we obtain with this is an
architecture which we call the sgnn oh
so by the way the first architecture we
call it dss gnn where dss stands for
deep sets of symmetric elements that is
the approach we uh we build on top of
but so what happens if we instead
neglect the second component information
sharing component so what we get is an
approach where we simply run
uh the same
message passing your network on each of
the subgraphs independently completely
independently without information
sharing
this is something like to some extent
reasonable to write is feasible but it
turns out
that this layer is not equivalent to the
direct product of the two permutation
groups
uh is actually equivalent to another
symmetry group which is a superset of
the
uh direct product group that we would
that we would like to we wanted to
actually model right
so if you remember i talked about node
alignment
and this is essentially what is not
preserved by the vreath product by this
new larger symmetry group so in the
second
approach so what i mean is that in the
second architecture uh no the nodes of
oscar graphs can be permuted
independently with respect to the nodes
in the other subgraphs
and
this layer which does not have this
information shared block will be
equivalent to
this permutation group which is larger
and in a way to be equivalent to this
larger permutation group the model will
be more constrained so we would expect
it to be less expressive and
i will comment on this
later
is there any questions so far it's uh
it's a little bit uh it's a lot i know
but yeah feel free to ask if you have
any question on this
so so good so far so good shall we
continue
yes yes
okay
let's go so
oh yeah so uh the slightest say that uh
this approach as you can see is very
general so we have this concept of
policy that generates a grass we have
this concept of um
uh processing the this in an equivalent
fashion and possibly also sharing
information uh what we observed is that
uh many of these approaches for example
the one we we discussed before can be
captured uh by by this framework which
by the way we called the governance of
graph aggregation networks
um
and so
in a sense this framework pays the way
to a unification and generalization of
subgraph gnns uh with bags of the graphs
and this uh through the lens of the
variance which i find it to be very
interesting
uh but the one of the first um
you know um starting point uh for us was
the uh you know the the the issue with
expressive power so what's the
expressive power of this architecture we
designed
um so in order to to study that to
characterize this we took a little
detour and we designed a combinatorial
algorithm that is a variant of the
standard wl algorithm um that works
actually on sub graphs and on on bags of
some graphs
um the dso is the following we
want to apply color refinement on each
subgraph in uh in the back
but we don't do this independently again
we share information as we know we could
do because of the small alignment
concept so the idea is that we
assign a color to each node in each
graph and we keep refining these colors
by this color refinement step if you
take a look is essentially similar to
the standard color final step in wl
but we have two additional inputs the
sparkle and green inputs here
so we didn't really have just the color
of the current color of the node we are
updating we also have as we we used to
have
uh the multi-set of colors of neighbors
where now the neighbors are the
neighbors according to a specific
subgraph s in this case
and then we have these two additional
inputs so the purple one cd is what we
call the needle color that is we collect
the color for the same note but across
different subgraphs in the back
and again this is possible exactly
because we have this concept of node
alignment
and then the fourth the last input
is what we call ambitious in green is
actually the math set of this needle
color or called needle color basically
these purple ones but for the neighbors
of the note v
and uh
basically
what happens is that we managed to prove
that there exists policies such that
uh this approach which we call dsswl is
strictly more powerful than one wl
um
and maybe i can also mention so you can
what you can do is you can also disable
these two new inputs
and in this case this the procedure
boils down to a performing standard wl
on each subgraph but independently right
and this we call it the swl
and even the swl for certain policies
can be shown to be strictly more
powerful than 1wl
and amongst these policies are those the
the most common policies which we
discussed before so for example no
deletion edge deletion and igor nets
now
okay
but uh what about the architecture so we
proved that the our architecture ds and
the ssgn can implement this
combinatorial variant this ds and the
sswl algorithms so this means there's a
corollary that there exists policies for
example not deletion education equinex
such that ds and the ssgn are strictly
more powerful than mpns which is what we
wanted to show at the very beginning
right
uh
so by designing this variant this
allowed us to more easily study compare
it with standard wl and that's why uh we
did it in the first place
but this may also be of in independent
interest
for commentary algorithms and
isomorphism tests
um so what about the ts versus the sg n
so we were saying that we would expect
the ssgn to be more expressive than the
sgn right
um so
um
yeah so we found some policies such that
exactly this this concept of node
alignment allows to reconstruct the
original graph whereas the sgn not
having alignment between nodes only sees
for example number of edges and it's not
able to reconstruct the original graph
so for certain policies we showed that
it is actually the case
uh that the ssg is more powerful than
the sgn
um
and in practicing experiments we've
observed that the ssgn tends to
outperform the sgnn in practice
and it's uh the ssg m is better than the
base encoder 91 of the time the base
encoder is the the uh gnn we use
as uh if you remember this uh equivalent
internal uh blocks
um so most of the time the ssg and n is
better than a standard gnn in practice
and the sdnn is better than a base
encoder 75 percent of the time so it's
still better just
it's more likely that with dss with this
information sharing component in
addition we get better results
um
so another interesting uh point is that
um the policy matters so the choice of
the policy
may have an impact on the expressive
power so what we managed to see to show
is that on the family of strongly
regular graphs which are these very
valid asymmetric regular graphs and very
hard cases for graphics or fission if we
use no deletion or depth and igor nets
you're not able to distinguish these
graphs so we have the same
discriminative power as 3w but if you
use for example edge deletion
then we suddenly we are able to
distinguish these graphs
and so it seems like edge deletion is
stronger as a stronger policy on
at least in this family of grass for
example
[Music]
in practice we didn't really observe a
strong correlation between the
performance of a policy and the
application domain but the ignite
policies uh seem to work very well in
practice like at least consistently
across uh
settings and different data sets
uh here we have an example on molecular
modeling so the zinc benchmark is um
about trying to predict uh constraint
solubility for molecules uh modulus
graphs and for example we observe that
uh as soon as we transition from edge
deletion nutrition to eagerness the
performance uh increase uh in the sense
that we have a lower um
mean absolute error on the test set
and you as you can already see the ssgn
seem to work much better than the sgnn
especially when we use the ignite boards
uh in general so we on this suite of
small data sets we observed uh this
approach to achieve uh good results with
compared to the state-of-the-art
approaches
and
as we were already anticipating it
generally improves on the accuracy of
the basin or the accuracy of the base
encoder this uh these are the results on
other molecular molding benchmarks from
the ogb suite
um i i think it's interesting to take a
look again at zinc but compared to other
um approaches so if we compare the the
the our the results we got with our
framework uh we
are the best performing model amongst
all probably expressive domain agnostic
gnns as you can see
and um sometimes you know
by a fair margin
uh the
on the on you know at the same time
uh we are very competitive and sometimes
uh even uh better than
gns which employee directly employs
specific information so for example
which include
explicitly the
information about the presence of rings
in molecules
uh and this was uh also one of the of
the the zederata we have at the
beginning right so we want a model to be
expressive but not necessarily uh to
really need to inject domain
knowledge into the architecture
um
right so let's wrap up we have taken a
look to this family of uh this wave of
new probably expressive gns which we
call subgraph gene ends
the common theme is that they leverage
sub graphs to uplift the expressive
power but still staying within the
remnants of message passing that is
often used as a subroutine right
we introduced e-scent that is this
framework um
uh that seems to unify concurrent works
and and this is uh done by studying the
emerging symmetry so the symmetry is
characterizing these objects as bags of
uh the advantage uh of this approach is
that
well or in general of subgraph gnns the
advantages are that they are probably
expressive
they have they are natively variant
and you'd really need little
pre-engineering uh
don't you don't really need to
be a domain expert
to design the architecture
sorry uh in terms of future directions i
guess it would be interesting to study
other policies or what's a little bit
more what's the input of the policy on
the on the expressive power and
performance in general
uh other things would be to study
structure bags so at the moment you know
bags have been considered to be sets but
we can also induce some particular so
like some more structure on it for
example consider them as grass if we
come up with an interesting notion of uh
connectivity between the graphs for
example uh and then uh yeah uh
i think there's work to do in studying
uh stochastic policies that is policies
which
subsample subgraphs um
because there is this um we have the
situation that we can still retain some
approximate form of equivalence and this
is still uh
very interesting because this would
allow us to reduce the computational
complexity but by still uh but still
retaining some form of approximate
environment so still this strong
inductive bias
on graphs
and with this uh i conclude the
presentation and uh
i'm happy to take any questions uh yeah
thank you thank you very much
yes thank you thank you for the issue so
there's a question in the chat
yes uh
dsswl and such methods are they are
evaluated
um okay so the sswl we
didn't really implement it in practice
in the sense that it was uh so it is a
combinatory algorithm we used in the in
you know on the on the theoretical side
to um
then study the expressiveness of
the neural counterpart and then we of
course implemented the neural
counterpart and that is the ssgn and the
sgnn and we applied it on a series of um
benchmarks in particular we focused on
molecular modeling so the idea is you uh
could you model a molecule as a
as a graph and then you apply our method
so what this doesn't mean to apply our
method on a molecule
defined as a graph it means that we take
the the graph corresponding to the
molecule and again as i was explaining
we we apply policy so we extract
subgraphs and we process the subgraphs
in an equivalent way
and and then in the end basically you
have a representation of freaks of graph
you aggregate these representations
again you know you know well in this
case in the end
in an invariant fashion and then you
you would like to give this
representation to a classified to
predict for example molecular properties
such as
um
toxicity and so on
so there are other
results
on on synthetic benchmarks i haven't
showed them to you but yeah we also
evaluated this approach in terms of like
purely in terms of its expressive power
so there are synthetic benchmarks where
people try to run gnns uh in an effort
to the zombie great uh
grass which we already know they are not
distinguishable by standard message by
senior networks so for example
uh yeah there are data sets of uh circle
skipping graphs and yeah we did it we
actually indeed evaluated the ss gnn
of these benchmarks and most of the
cases we got perfect accuracy
um
mostly because yeah
the i mean this this
basically uh showed that yeah the
approach is indeed uh as indeed more
expressive than standard mesh passenger
networks which they have random gas
accuracy on these benchmarks but still
um
yeah uh this
graphs were usually like
uh
3wl distinguishable so yeah this
explains also why we really managed to
get up to 100
um
yeah um
so we we did this kind of evaluation if
it's what you were asking about the
expressive power yes
um so if we uh were to go back to the
start policy when using the iso
framework
we
[Music]
go back to double networks oh okay very
interesting
um
so instead of considering economists you
consider stars
um
let me think about it
i
so
if you
yeah if you don't do anything uh
particular
um
yes i guess you would get back to the
summer wl
yeah
if it's for example just one
it depends also on well so if you take
for example pswl
and you extract stars
so if stars are just one of stars for
each and it's a graph it's a one of star
and you don't have any information
sharing
actually what happens is that
it might even be less expressive than
mobile because you're not able to
basically propagate information from
other nodes so
the algorithm would
converge very very quickly so if the
star is shallow it may also potentially
lose expressive power in this case if
you have a form of information sharing
for example this needle coloring maybe
you can make do with that and maybe you
can get to one w two just not the wl but
yes this uh as you can see yeah some
policies are very trivial and are
actually
not useful or detrimental
for example another one is you simply
take edges
you have like it's a graph is an edge
right so this is also a very
non useful policy
yes
but she had a very interesting question
so we have some intuition on how to
choose the policies in the future uh
yeah good question
um so as i was saying we don't really
want to have uh free engineering but
there's still some engineering in the
sense that it's like what how do you
choose the policy right
um
so in general um
as we were saying the eco policy works
very well
um
typically
similar like comparable or is comparable
to modulation or even better
um
this is an active also area i think
well not
you know don't see papers exactly on
designing policies but
there are new policies emerging in
recent papers for example there are new
papers where people try to use note
marking instead of notation and they
show that this uh
basically substitute notation so the
idea is you don't necessarily need to
delete an unknown you can mark it with a
special feature
and the fact that you mark this with
special feature actually
allows you to this allows you to um
still breaks images but without actually
altering the connectivity and the idea
is you can
simulate or whatever with modulation
anyway
another thing is
we now i think we we have also a better
understanding of what does or what it
means to choose a policy like what's the
impact of the policy so
there's
some new more recent work i i
i did for example um it's uh
we we realize you can also gather
um policies in classes for example you
have policies which are intrinsically
not based right so if you think of
economics or
not marking or not deletion you can
always find a bijection between a node
international graph and a subgraph
engine rate
so this uh this actually gives you more
structure and you can
consider them in a class and study the
the like for the characteristic of this
class of policies and we actually did it
and we found out that
uh if you
all if you have this kind of policies
you always have an upper bound in
expressive power
if you use a standard npn encoder which
is 3w
so
this you know the upshot is that if you
want to go beyond 3wl with uh with an
npn base encoder you need a policy which
is
not not based for example something like
edge base or you know you mark two notes
at a time
you you delete one edge at a time
so yeah there's some at least some
recent work uh which i really tries to
uh characterize these policies into
like for example uh classify them into
classes and study
you know the
um
yeah the
features of this classes these families
of policies and their limitations so
yeah for sure there's some some work
with this
um
in general if you have domain knowledge
uh it's always good to take that into
account if you want to design a new
policy but yeah uh this is what i can
probably answer at the moment
thank you thank you for the question
very great yeah they're really they will
questions
uh if there's nothing else uh yeah i can
also mention maybe related to this
question let me uh
uh
top up on this
um
i forgot to say that there are also
works uh recent works the recent words
we try to um
learn the policy directly so instead of
designing the policy what you could do
is you can learn it and to end for
example with some
um
particular uh
you know approach to
uh back propagate through
you know discrete structures uh so
well you could do it for example with
reinforcement learning so the problem is
essentially that uh the selection of
edges you know these are discrete
operations and it's
it's not really
obvious how to back propagate through
this
uh
through the policy itself
but
uh
you can for example make do with
reinforcement learning or something
which seems to be also
um
very uh effective that is to use
approaches like based on preparations uh
for um
like implicit differentiation and uh
propagation through the street
structures
um so there are this works with which
basically
through the combinatory algorithms and
they have been tried
like there's been an attempt to use
these approaches to their policies it's
uh like the policy itself from
from from data directly while uh like in
an end-to-end fashion
uh if you're interested in this so there
is uh like this approach that's called
implicit uh
maximum likelihood estimation imle
uh which tries to do this kind of thing
so the idea is for example you
you want to propagate through say uh
an integer linear programming
uh problem for example like or something
like i don't know
uh dijkstra for shortest path
uh it is you can do this with some
tricks and um
based on
perturbations and uh yeah you can then
basically
learn the parameters of this mixed
models and
yeah so there's some work on this as
well
i'm not an expert in this kind of
approaches but uh yeah for sure
there's movements on that side as well